vladimir putin the president of russia
recently gave a speech he was talking
about the united states and europe
monetary policy inflation and a whole
bunch of geopolitical uncertainty now of
course we're unlikely to hear about this
in the western media so i found this
twitter thread here which gives us a
little bit of a translation of exactly
what putin said
first up he stated the very principles
of the global economic system have taken
a blow fundamental business notions as
business reputation the invaluability of
property and trust in global currencies
have been seriously damaged when i spoke
at the davos forum a year and a half ago
i also stressed that the era of a
unipolar world order has come to an end
i want to start with this as there's no
way around it this era has ended despite
all the attempts to maintain and
preserve it at all cost then putin went
on to talk about sanctions where he said
that sanctions as a weapon have proved
in recent years to be a double-edged
sword damaging their advocates and
architects just as much if not more
we see social and economic problems
worsening in europe and in the us as
well food electricity and fuel prices
rising with quality of life in europe
falling and companies losing their
market edge the european union has lost
its political sovereignty and its
bureaucratic elites are dancing to
someone else's tune doing everything
they are told from on high and hurting
their own people economies and
businesses
surging inflation in product and
commodity markets had become a fact of
life long before this year the world has
been driven into this by years of
irresponsible macroeconomic policies
pursued by g7 countries including
uncontrolled emission and accumulation
of unsecured debt because they could not
or would not devise any other recipes
the governments of the leading western
economy simply accelerated their money
printing machines such a simple way to
make up for unprecedented budget
deficits i have already cited this
figure over the past two years the money
supply in the united states has grown by
more than 38 percent the eu's money
supply has also increased dramatically
over this period it grew by about 20 or
2.5 trillion euros we all hear about the
so-called putin inflation in the west
when i see this i wonder who they expect
would buy this nonsense people who
cannot read or write maybe
anyone literate enough to read would
understand what is actually happening
so they printed more money and then what
where did all that money go it was
obviously used to pay for goods and
services outside western countries this
is where the newly printed money flowed
they literally began to clean out to
wipe out global markets while at the end
of 2019 imports of goods to the united
states amounted to about 250 billion
dollars a month by now it has grown to
350 billion it is noteworthy that the
growth was 40
exactly in proportion to the unsecured
money supply printed in recent years
america's role has changed drastically
it has turned from a net exporter of
food into a net importer loosely
speaking it is printing money and
pulling commodity flows its way buying
food products all over the world
the european union is building up
imports even faster obviously such a
sharp increase in demand that is not
covered by the supply of goods has
triggered a wave of shortages and global
inflation and then here it is
under the cloud of inflation many
developing nations are asking a good
question why exchange goods for dollars
and euros that are losing value right
before our eyes
global currency reserves are at 7.1
trillion and 2.5 trillion euros now
these reserves are devalued at an annual
rate of about 8 percent
moreover they can be confiscated or
stolen anytime if the united states
dislikes something in the policy of the
states involved i think this has become
a very real threat for many countries
that keep their gold and foreign
exchange reserves in these currencies a
conversion of global reserves will begin
it will be converted from weakening
currencies into real resources like food
energy commodities and other raw
materials obviously this process will go
further fuel global dollar inflation now
of course there's plenty of people who
would say vladimir putin he's not a good
guy he literally invaded ukraine he's
killing people and he's causing all
sorts of geopolitical chaos i don't
disagree but what i do know is that
vladimir putin the president of russia
appears to be more honest and
transparent about his views on the
global economy and the united states and
inflation than our own economic leaders
now of course there's plenty of nuance
involved in this debate there's all
sorts of details like supply chains and
covid and various other policies at play
but one thing is certain is that in the
united states we were sold a story of
inflation as transitory and now we're
being sold a story that a recession is
not imminent but what we have is an
individual that has been operating on
the global stage for years and years and
he's saying you have high inflation
because you expanded your money supply
by 38
over the last two years
now many people won't listen to this
warning they'll actually ignore it
because of who's saying it but put aside
for a second who the person is i don't
agree with them either but you have to
understand that this is a very serious
situation inflation's at a 40-year high
the federal reserve is raising interest
rates they're trying to conduct
quantitative tightening they want to
crash asset prices and destroy demand
which risk pushing us into a recession
ultimately on the geopolitical stage
america is wobbling this is the greatest
country in the world we literally are
the shining light on the hill and if we
want to continue in our leadership
position on that global stage we got to
get our act together we got to
strengthen the dollar even more we have
to get rid of the high inflation and
we've got to do our best to avoid
pushing ourselves into a recession
that's no easy task i don't envy the
central bankers it's basically a
lose-lose situation but let's not get
gas lit by our politicians and central
bankers at the exact same time
what we are watching
in the destruction of the dollar's value
and a potential recession is driven by
market intervention by central bankers
and politicians undisciplined monetary
and fiscal policy is driving a lot of
this
i don't think that many people in the
united states see free markets here
anymore but we should return to those we
should stop intervening we should allow
the free market to do what it's designed
to do it will use economic incentives to
get market participants to find
equilibriums stabilize prices and
ultimately let us grow out of our
problems hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time